and i'll tell you what this young man
right here is no longer a rookie no
longer a prospect he is now pitching
like a veteran and it's going to be fun
to watch him tonight as he gets ready to
make his second start of the season
hits this one on a line to left pilot
comes out and makes a sliding catch
road lays a line drive pollock a nice
play and we are underway
zimmerman scorches another one it's off
the glove and into left center off of
corey seeger so ryan zimmerman sends
soda to third what a fantastic a b
that was gets castro up there with two
gone
castro jammed right field mckinstry long
run can't get it that's lead one nothing
and over at third base ryan zimmerman's
out
outfield assist from mckinstry but not
before the nationals get the game's
first run 31 year old left-hander
patrick corbin the native of clay new
york upstate new york as he makes his
2021 debut
21 games 19 career starts 5-9 overall 31
years old 6-3 2-10 faces the dodgers for
the 22nd time here's yesterday's home
run
justin turner
1-2
corbin started to change up away did you
see justin turner look back at him like
what in the world was that
the lead-off man aboard one-two pitch
got him
with the change-up first strike out of
the game for julio
so one thing we've noticed about julio's
change-up this year it's about two mile
an hour faster this at 88.
you know julio can go up there around 96
97 sometimes but he won't pitch there
maria's come set checking the runner
mercer at first and the pitch breaking
ball looped in the air a base hit over
the second baseman looks into right
center to second is mercer slams the
brakes on
his second corbin at first maria's home
with an o2
fastball he's blind right back to aria
standing
another payoff pitch
taken from ball four
quite an eye the sound catcher has he's
aboard first base runner against corbin
yeah that's a walk from muncie
back-to-back walks against corbin to
open this second and even the dodgers in
business aj pollock comes up
the 3-1
inside and low ball four
and corbin has walked the faces loaded
with nobody out here in the second okay
now if your gavin lux is going to be the
hitter which approach are you taking
base has loaded nobody out in a payoff
pitch
left side
one play at home
good stretch by gomes on a throw from
castro who picked up the sharply hit
ball bases loaded one out a one-nothing
game the eight-hitter mckinstry's up
based right field
muncie's in the score pollux headed for
the plate soto's throw
bounces off guns and the dodgers take a
two long lead
the rookie mckinster delivers
the chemistry can't be looking for the
fastball in but he gets one and ends up
down the middle of the plate he rakes
this ball into right field there's two
out now here comes chris taylor his
first one to taylor
is blasted little forget about it
chris taylor
is off to an impossibly hot start this
year
a three-run shot and the dodgers now
lead it
5-1
that was fresh
change up tap back to aureus can you get
the fastest man in baseball just barely
another 2-2
fly ball center field taylor going back
[Applause]
two outs in the third at 52.
washington making a grind a lot of foul
balls
zimmerman with a bullet that's speared
by locks
here's a 1-1
smith with a fly ball to center field
deep row blaze going back way back and
it is high off the wall
will smith missed a home run by maybe a
foot he'll have to settle for a sliding
head first double this here's muncie
this is part of the order that god has
started last inning with three
consecutive walks against corbin muncie
yanks one past the shift piercing it to
right smith had to wait to make sure
that it wasn't caught on the fly so he
advances to third but now the dodgers
have first and third one out and aj
pollock coming up
there it is
just what you need
turner and then mercer zimmerman 6-4-3
and a big double play ball for patrick
corbin patrick corbin bottom three lux
mckinstry and urias 3-2
that's a great pitch
lux thought he might have walked brian
gorman punches him out
patrick corbin's second strikeout
perfect pitch good frame by on gums see
he really have to frame it he knows the
strike throw it around the o2 ball in
the dirt swung out and missed gomes
blocks out in front of the plate picks
it up and throws down to first and
patrick corbin has back-to-back
strikeouts
the two-two swinging miss struck him out
on an up-and-in fastball and
corbin strikes out the side in the
fourth
the wind and corbin's one two swing
swinging a mess at a slider that one
dulled down
below the strike zone and
taylor strikes out so corbin has fanned
four to row in five of the game now
first down to the bottom of the fifth
and seeger coming up
[Applause]
so seeger is a board justin turner
coming up proceeds going to charity
turner to left center field towards the
gap it will split it
up against the wall seeger read it well
he hits third and heads home turner will
throw to the plate not even close to him
justin trudeau with an rbi double and at
6-1 as he drives in his ninth of the
year to lead the clock
ureas has set down 11 consecutive
hitters soto a grounder and a fly ball
to center
fastball soto rips it see
you later
about a third of the way up the pavilion
and juan soto has his first of the year
there we go offense is cool juan soto
110 mile an hour tater
he knows something about hitting home
runs in this ballpark doesn't he
the nationals have runners at first and
third and john gomes four homers 13 rbis
in 30 games last year
and he fights one off and that's a base
hit zimmerman scores
6-3
up to jimmy nelson to try and keep that
line right there
mercer is at third
gomes at second and now hernandez at
first all those guys reaching with two
outs as stevenson steps in the set
the one-two
nelson strikes him out doubling up on
the curve ball
pitcher for the nationals this is kyle
finnegan dodgers have the bases loaded
leading 6-3 here in the seventh
finnegan's on to face aj [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
it will unload
[Applause]
aj pollock did an awful lot of studying
as finnegan came in and took his
warm-ups grant brown and he went over
the scouting report
one scouting report they looked at then
they looked at a second one and it
looked like it worked
he squares this ball up and you've got
to go for it to get the third one you're
already down by three it's do or die
right here
and that might put the game on ice
juan soto gets to bat now the pitch
swing and fouled that one off his foot
of the box and he goes hobbling away
director of athletic training his
manager davey martinez finally come out
he's gonna be okay though
and soto laces one to right and it's a
nine to five ball game on one second of
the night and the year you called it he
was locked in at all that bat so luke
roy a pitch hit single one out away from
a win
[Applause]
[Music]
the final score